[Music]
master chief the covenant and even
energy swords get time to shine in the
series premiere of halo but a mysterious
relic of unknown origin might be the
episode's most important thing warning
spoilers ahead for halo episode 1
humanity's best weapon
after years spent in development the
official halo tv series is finally here
the first entry in the series introduces
audiences to the world of halo through
the eyes of quan ha a 16 year old girl
whose home planet is attacked by
covenant forces although we spend most
of the first hour with kwan and spartan
super soldier master chief the first
chapter is also chalk full of detail
when it comes to the political affairs
of the halo universe and the scientific
research of dr catherine halsey of the
united nations space command the first
episode undeniably throws a lot of
exposition at both halo video game
veterans and franchise newbies so it's
understandable that some may be a little
confused at the end of the first hour
luckily if you've got a question about
where halo episode 1 leaves things
you've come to the right place of course
one of the biggest questions many fans
have been asking about the halo tv
series is the same question that has
also long haunted the video game
franchise will we see master chief's
space while the video game version of
the character has yet to reveal a
complete view of what lies underneath
his helmet the television series is
already taking a different approach for
the first 50 minutes of the nearly 57
minutes long episode master chief is
only ever seen with this helmet securely
fastened to the rest of his tactical
uniform regardless of whether the
warrior is in the middle of a battle or
relaxing in a spaceship master chief's
helmet seems to be as much a part of him
as any other body part it ultimately
takes a big moment in the episode for
the legendary spartan to bear his face
in the climax of the pilot episode
master chief removes his helmet during a
confrontation with quan a recently
orphaned 16 year old girl and the sole
survivor of a covenant attack on
madrigal although quan holds master
chief at gunpoint he confidently points
out that the caliber of ammunition in a
rifle wouldn't even manage to dent his
specially designed armor in order to
prove his loyalty to her master chief
slowly lifts his helmet off his head
leaving himself more vulnerable to
attack than we've ever seen before
if you want me dead
you'll need to aim up here
luckily for both of them quan quickly
decides that master chief is better as
an ally one of the mysteries at the core
of the series so far focuses on a
covenant relic that seems to be uniquely
tied to master chief when the super
soldier first makes physical contact
with the device a bright light emerges
surprising master chiefs fellow spartans
and a nearby member of the covenant even
more surprisingly however the device
appears to trigger old memories in
master chief's head while this trip down
memory lane is visibly noteworthy to the
spartan it isn't until much later in the
episode that the device's true potential
is revealed for reasons he is unable to
fully explain master chief subsequently
refuses a unsc order to execute kwon
realizing that a return to reach would
mean a certain death sentence for his
new traveling companion master chief
scrambles at the last minute to redirect
his ship but only manages to deactivate
the autopilot mere seconds before
landing in response the unsc fires an
electromagnetic pulse at his ship
immediately grounding it when all looks
to be surely doomed master chief simply
reaches out to the relic triggering a
flurry of new memories including what
looks to be a child's drawing of the
very same device more importantly
however the device quickly powers up the
recently disabled ship allowing the duo
to escape obviously this raises a number
of important questions what is the
purpose of the device and who made it so
far a covenant human named mackie is the
only person other than master chief who
is able to bring it to life obviously
something which suggests a prior
relationship of some sort between the
two perhaps learning more about the
origins of this show's protagonist will
also eventually provide answers about
this mysterious relic eagle-eyed viewers
will notice that while most members of
the unsc are quite unhappy to see master
chief's spaceship depart as abruptly as
it arrived a smile appears on the lips
of the spartan program leader in the
final moments of the episode so why is
halsey smiling while her multi-billion
dollar super soldier flies away with a
rebel we think it probably has something
to do with the influence the covenant
relic is having on master chief i think
he's having memories
although halsey is visibly astonished at
the device's capabilities she never
seems especially eager to see other
members of the unsc get their hands on
the device while she admits to being
somewhat worried that master chief
unlocking his suppressed memories could
produce unexpected results she actually
does her best to cover for him when he
initially begins acting out notably
halsey is also rather quick to suggest
solving this problem via the
implementation of something called
cortana a name that all halo video game
fans everywhere will surely recognize
although she is obviously unwilling to
voice it right now it also remains
possible that halsey has ulterior
motives of some form in the halo video
games halsey is extremely dedicated to
the members of her spartan program
especially master chief while it remains
to be seen if the tv version of halsey
would ever be willing to choose master
chief over the unsc it certainly seems
like something that will be a point of
contention moving forward new episodes
of halo drop on paramount plus every
thursday check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]